going on it's bill burr and it's time
for the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast Anna I'm
just checking in on you this is not an
official podcast this is where I just
check in on you on a Thursday see how
your [ __ ] workweek is going and most
times what you know the deal I do it by
myself I lay around I shoot the [ __ ] I
say things people hear things they think
that it's about them
and who is or isn't in the white house
who the [ __ ] knows but every once in a
while I bring on a guest and when I do I
don't just bring on any guests I bring
on some of the most talented people out
there and some of my great friends and
today this is no different I have the
great Ben Bailey from Cash Cab he's got
a new special he's got a bunch of short
films he's got a new websites got a
bunch of [ __ ] he wants to talk about Ben
Bailey what's up man
how the [ __ ] are you I'm good dude good
we see a youtuber now I have when was
the last time I saw you it wasn't last
November ah might have been and we're
not seeing you once since then but we
had to have some sort of festival yeah
yeah maybe out here but you're talking
to walking by to some social media tent
you're talking about a Madison Square
Garden no last November was that a year
ago already yeah it was it was the the
no longer Toyota Comedy Festival already
is it done isn't just a New York house
New York no yet do you member how many
years when we were in New York I came to
New York and like 95 right I believe in
yeah that's just a couple years after me
I started out here and then went back
there okay and we did like what we did
like maybe four or five thousand shows
together
yes I'm like that I literally sat down
one time and this is 15 years ago now or
maybe like 12 somewhere in there and I
try to sort of have you know add up some
idea of how many stand-up shows I had
done what do you think I came up with
10,000 yeah it was that was you know at
least 10 years ago probably more and you
kind of show is every time you go on
yeah yeah just any set I did anyway
that's fair because any time you go up
god knows what the [ __ ] happy yeah
yeah it doesn't matter if it's four or
five minutes yeah somebody can still
there's plenty of time you have
something thrown at you yeah awful I you
know something I I remember I kept calm
until about like 26 into 30 maybe and
then I just lost it but I'm about really
you keep a track of how many you
done yeah it probably did too I don't
even remember but I probably did too
yeah I was always jealous of people that
did that because I'm sort of like like i
like i hate stats and like trying to
figure out what people where people are
socially but I love them in sports
because they're great they're like
they're kind of fact as far as like how
many home runs you hit you know that
that's like a ladder to it gives you
some something to go up against yeah but
I don't find love [ __ ] like you know
though when it's raining out and will
blow when you get to that [ __ ] like I'm
more into the how many yards that this
guy throw for how many do you run or
whatever stuff like that right not at
specific situations they do break it
down a little too far you like what yeah
it's see the reason because we have like
9 19 maybe 24 hours sports networks plus
the internet plus [ __ ] like me and
all that it the whole thing it's just
way too much information and what I was
trying to get to was do you remember
when the Toyota Comedy Festival first
came around yeah was the funniest [ __ ]
ever it was just as they would say that
it was the festival there was like
nobody I ever met that was connected
with it they were just hang a banner it
was just a banner at the regular clubs
yeah and was all the same regular
performers there was no industry and
just feelin MMSD would leave on this
weekend you have the Toyota Comedy
Festival and we have Ben Bailey Bill
burr Godfrey was all the same it was a
banner we used it took us like we were
all so excited because we had nothing
going on in our careers yeah I'm part of
the festival it took about three years
before somebody fine just said you know
what what is this [ __ ] Leon's like
gayest of all this is every this is a
regular Wednesday right and somehow
though that morphed into an actual
festival or the New York Comedy Festival
right which is I think is you know
there's a lot of festivals you know out
there but like New York City you got to
have a big Comedy Festival yeah I think
so I think it's great I was actually I
wasn't been a part of it really but I'm
supposed to be next to you later for the
first nine years when it was yeah I
understand yeah that was part of it for
the first nine and then they started
booking people and I missed the cut yeah
[ __ ] I don't know yeah you and me both I
can over the the New York underground
Comedy Festival I don't think I was a
part of that I'm sure I submitted a VHS
tape to it
the joke was that it was so underground
that and literally no one knew about it
was it valid like surf reality it was
the same thing it was like it was like a
banner at a couple of clubs you know and
some guys some guy had a bunch of money
was i coming to have a festival you know
that's a great way in from LA and stuff
and these guys would come in they're
like yeah we're for the festival and
we're all like what what are you talking
about I'm sure we greeted them warmly
well the last time well I guess sort of
meandering my weight towards was that
Toyota of Comedy Festival then morphed
into the New York Comedy Festival right
and that's what that the MSG gig was
last year and as I mention aging as I
mentioned to you guys you know obviously
that was a nerve-wracking gig and I just
you know I don't I can't remember how
the [ __ ] came about pride from doing the
goddamn Comedy Jam or whatever I was
like right I've asked my agent I was
like hey wait we paid to rent that thing
all day right considering 90% of the
money is gonna go right back to renting
that giant [ __ ] place I go yeah I
said can I like rent a drum kit first I
was just gonna rent a drum kit and just
jam with my you know my music by myself
typical comedian tour I isolated but
because of Josh Adam eiders in the
goddamn Comedy Jam so the people they're
like we're gonna be in town so I rented
all this gear and there's this running
thing with me and Ben word for about
eight years we were trying to get
together and play music you play drums I
think at the time are we gonna get
together every [ __ ] time he'd come
out here to LA and it's like he's
running around he's got meetings he
couldn't [ __ ] make it and then I get
to New York and he you're out in Jersey
and that's just when you don't have a
[ __ ] car it's like oh my god I'm
gonna get on the path train do or like
have anybody to come out gypsy cab so
finally like we're just like I'd come to
town and we were gonna jam and then
that's when I finally solidified and I
was gonna drive out to your place so and
you are all excited cuz you've made it
yeah yeah you know that I built and
everything I'm like aw we're finally
gonna play in it and he's all amped up
tell me how great his [ __ ] studio is
and I was like I don't know man I think
I got a better place yeah you're like I
got a better place I'm like yeah what
the [ __ ] and I just said
I didn't give you the address I think I
told you was MSG I said well I finally I
wrote back where like I was like it must
be someplace good yeah he's not just
slamming my home studio that I built
without having seen it must have sup MSG
and like monosodium glutamate yeah
[ __ ] Madison Square Garden man I knew
when I said I have a better place your
next text was gonna come back in all
capitals and doesn't take any [ __ ] from
anybody and he's actually big enough to
beat the [ __ ] I mean about twenty
other people so he's what the [ __ ] I
totally insulted a studio so what do you
need a better place yeah so we ended up
coming down and as I mentioned before is
that my phone Jesus Christ bill can you
feel it just makes it real listen it
makes people feel like they're actually
in the studio witnessing how
unprofessional this is how many of them
like jumped up and looked around I know
cuz I do have when the flow rates
they're like oh oh no that's that's the
standard way hiding in the closet and
there's a serial killer walking around
you know there's a chance when your
phone rings he won't know what shoe
he'll think it's he'll think it's his
fault for a second maybe you can drop
all them look at it you [ __ ] smother
them with your PJs oh it's a great scene
in a film right there oh yeah you got a
killer checks his own phone he's a god
yeah could you once in your life be
professional speaking of playing music
is I have like the hearing damage that I
have which is inevitable if you play or
you do this [ __ ] rate of the hearing
damage that I have is I actually got my
hearing check like I still can hear
everything but I have a little bit of
displacement as to where it is like
it'll be told right and I start going to
the left get my life just resting man
just laughs at me yeah as long as it
stays from doing stand-up and like
playing music and yeah headphones alt I
know Opie from myopia nathie says my
ears are shot because what happens is
your ears get tired you know you keep
turning up and turning up it's all about
the directional right yeah you guys do
like four hours a day and I try to be
conscious of it but like I [ __ ] my
ears up in the 80s one of my ears I got
that tinnitus yeah
rings it a real low-level or if I'm
really hung over it but I mean I don't
have like like to the Pete Townsend
level but uh so anyway it's getting back
to it so it doesn't he had to quit I
don't see right but not from the music
from racecar driving she's like what I
was from yeah that's what they said it
wasn't you know he's he's been an ac/dc
all these years like the loudest [ __ ]
band but no that's not why his ears are
damages from driving race cars one of my
first times I really [ __ ] my ears up
as I saw them on the was they hate
secret tour oh no I saw Amit mad I saw
him at the Boston Garden nice
I think Cinderella opened no no I saw
him down in Providence was a different
tour I saw them a bunch of time who made
who Heatseeker all during that whole
period I used to go see him and I didn't
have earplugs and as loud as that was
the [ __ ] dude driving home he had the
[ __ ] thing turned all the way up to
[ __ ] ten and I remember just like
sitting in the back just taking it
rather than ask him hey can you turn
that down you're making all but no I I
had like that German Irish just like
yeah don't complain don't complain
suffer in silence yes it'll it'll be
over soon as well when you're in the
back of a car and the guy's driving like
a [ __ ] maniac and I'm like being
polite yeah I'm like I don't want to
offend him by asking him to slow down or
whatever I'd rather just risk my own
death hey not that guy not trying to be
that guy but I'd like to live yeah I'd
like to survive this ride yeah I don't
to be in a halo at the end of this but
anyway so we finally ended up getting to
play at Madison Square Garden I think it
was worth the [ __ ] way it was worth
it was our Chinese Democracy dude I got
to tell you man I wouldn't change a
thing you [ __ ] can play oh really
play man I was really a cute onus is
crazy and I got I got to show that to uh
you know a bunch of people when I got to
do the Tonight Show yeah I showed it to
question Fallon and stuff I think I
showed sure I said show too and they
were just like wow man askew should have
given us you know Jimmy's all you should
get mr. video we would have Plato's just
like alright dude it's not that good
that was so fun dude it really was it
really wasn't John's going off and
surreal day yeah and I had my dad every
so many people play through like my
agent went out and played he almost
didn't go ahead at twist his arm yeah
yeah Berkowitz yeah go up there
I helped you drag him up there I was
like come on dude yeah little wing or so
Michael O'Brien he [ __ ] ran up oh
yeah hey Mike you want any just ran
right up he was great too man so that
was a [ __ ] great day dude and your
show was awesome and I didn't know
anything about efforts for family before
that night oh no you guys played the the
preview of it that was the first time I
was like holy [ __ ] this is gonna be
awesome oh yeah so right
well we got another ten episodes of that
coming out but uh we're here just we're
here to uh promote your stuff let's
start with your website the real Ben
Bailey com that's your relaunch in your
website are you just I'm relaunching
it's been kind of just you know very
basic for a long time and I was like you
know what it it's time to just start
making my own stuff and putting it out
directly to people because there's no
reason to go and try and sell you know
like there's two short films on there
that I made that I really love what's
the one would Judah Friedlander that you
made a while ago I'm dying to see that
do it it's funny it's it's called meet
me at Ray's right and we made it like
way back in like 2002 or something 2003
and we're crazy busy after that and it
just sat there and I'm just I just
looked at him like I got to put this
thing out so it's just about two idiots
meeting up for pizza at Ray's pizza in
New York you know but there's there's a
lot of Ray's pizzas
you got a little busy at 14 years later
I'm like all right let's put this thing
out and then what happened during those
14 years he started doing all the movies
you did the cash cab thing yeah yeah
that was so cool watching you guys like
blowing up like I felt like I'd our
generation kind of had like an even
thing was just like nobody knew who we
were and then all of a sudden like
everybody started like just got some
inroads I don't know what happened yeah
yeah felt like going nowhere you know I
mean Jude and I used to sit in his
minivan at the end of nights of stand up
in the audience be like man this is
brutal
we got nothing yeah got nothing going on
you know dude I remember being in New
York and then BOOM and I moved back from
LA the first time I was out here and I
had a I lost my booking agent
I had no manager I had no agent and I
was incorporated as a business and I
just cost me too much money I got on
corporated right instead of paying to be
in court yeah because I wasn't making
any money and I went all the way back to
square one and I was living in that
walkthrough bedroom apartment with the
guy who was on the lease and it was me
and Bobby Kelly we had a lot of fun but
there was definitely nights it was
probably good that I was living with
Bobby because we'd laugh until you know
you know the late night and then I man
take it easy but if I had to go home and
just be with my own thoughts that
happened that yeah yeah after he moved
out and then I moved out and then there
was that period about 2000 to 2004 where
yeah there was a lot of taste just
waking up going like what am i doing
yeah what the [ __ ] I mean dude I had I
mean from 2000 2004 I think somewhere in
there I did get a half hour right but
there was like a thousand right the guy
came to your half hour the Comedy
Central one yeah I think yeah it was
like a good three-year area down yeah
just being like okay 33 years old
yeah 34 years old 35 you know this was
not planned I mean I thought it was okay
yeah yeah it was yeah and then the whole
alt scene was coming up yeah and that
whole thing blew up and then we were
just the [ __ ] house cast that was
that was rough in when the alternative
comedy club scene developed and then
just became this big thing you couldn't
drag yeah we're just in the in the
mainstream clubs like oops yeah you had
no idea if you're not gonna move to
those places yeah those were yeah those
are rough ones you know but we've seen
that I changed yeah so you made that
thing like 15 years ago what's this
other movie that you have coming up
because I know you're going to this
screening here which is really cool this
one's called blam BAM you badly-written
action man yeah yeah it's just I you
know action movies the action stars it
there they are badly written in a manner
of I think it's got a lot of quality in
those points there but but they're like
one-liners are like at least kind of
clever witty you know yeah even if
they're over the net off some steam yeah
yeah totally so I was like I just
thought I thought of this character one
day I can't remember what I was doing
aware but I just like it'd be funny if
you know so much of those movies now are
built around those lines if when you
finally get to
but you know one of those lines it's
just awful just no payoff yeah it's just
no payoff at all
you know which is like an anti payoff
really so it's kind of a crazy concept
but it just sort of fell together like
and how long are these movies they're
both about ten minutes and this is like
the type of stuff you can start putting
on the real Ben Bailey calm just yeah
yeah yeah I think that's a smart idea
because those those shorts I'm just
psyched about it they end up turning
into something they turn into movies and
that's one thing I've learned about this
business this is just like when you make
that decision like if this feels right
I'm gonna do this so many people they do
it one two times and when Spielberg Oh
Oprah doesn't want to interview you or
somebody right like well that sucks
focus business I tried you just got to
keep going because then when one of them
hits then they go back to your whole
library yeah and you got all of that
stuff and they'll something will will
turn into a but um I hope you're right
about that dude hey how long have you
put a lot into them boy M is about ten
minutes and it's and it's it's badly
written Action Man which was originally
badly written an action star right and
then Lenny Marcus and I were working on
writing throwing around ideas about it
and he was abbreviating it when he wrote
back to be lwas Blas or whatever right
and that made me go like oh maybe maybe
there's something in the acronym right
and then I was like oh if I make it
badly written Action Man then that's
blam and that's like a badly written
sound effect it's like boom
hey no it just kind of fell together you
know when you feel like something's
working yeah I had all these ideas and
that one when it was that little stuff
like that just moved to the front so I
just made it when did you shoot that one
in July
oh cool well there you go now you've
really stepped it up yeah one took you
12 years this one took you about 12
weeks ends on a tear now Jesus Christ
but it's cool D see Benny's in it and
he's a doctor in it he's a great actor
DC dude he's so good in this he's so
funny he's the evil villain and in boy
and there's no one oh man I'm gonna
watch this and this is gonna be amazed
in it Vecchio anis in it
Ian's a riot was obvious in it sorry I
was late dude he'd be a perfect
henchman so yeah I'm a Savia how we know
him he used to run the old Boston comedy
club which is now huge [ __ ] was
tasting a wine bar that's a wine bar yet
I walked in there one night just I had
to go in and look at it and there was
all these you know people in there you
know 20s you know primer their [ __ ]
life like we used to be and I just was
going like you know I can I help you sir
and I was just like this old man they
were like really and I was like yeah I
go I I watched like a 20 year old Dave
Chappelle right where that two top is
and that was at first they didn't give a
[ __ ] till I dropped him so he said
Chappelle you leave and I was like all
offended like how come you don't know
what's important to me totally I know
that I feeling yeah it's just like well
because we moved on old man now I like a
merlot I'll get the [ __ ] out of here
leaving
I know downstairs of that place is now
the zinc bar that was used to be called
the beacon cafe used to be the the
baguette in the bag in it and we used to
drink in there commit hard I remember
that kid with the glasses the kid on the
guitar he come down and [ __ ] like
wail like every Monday night at Coker
holy [ __ ] that guy David Coker yeah I've
still been in touch with him man he we
did a song for my last special Coker and
I wrote a song and did it and play it at
the end
- cab blues silly like you know Cash Cab
blues to him right because the guy loved
Coker so much he's such a great musician
man you really how long you been playing
by the way since I was 12
yeah you can 12 years old I the guy
lived on this English family moved in
behind us this is eight weeks and hello
it's your yard this is your garden
Oregon oh I'm sorry about that my last
podcast like every [ __ ] ingredient
spice they would say differently yeah so
yeah there's a lot of little Basel
Oregon Oh that'll do my girlfriend
you've met my girl right she's
Australian I have a new bit around one
of those little things that that still
come up these little differences between
how they speak and how we speak and she
said uh I talked about my daughter going
horse riding right and like horse riding
we say horseback riding and then I'm
like why do we specify
yeah horse riding actually makes a lot
more sense they kind of get me only ever
ride on one part of the horse before
spec ready yeah yeah but you said horse
riding get off its neck yeah yeah horse
neck and I have this whole bit about it
but there's so many little things like
that but so these British got these
British family moves in behind us the
oldest brother is like I'm like I'm 11
what are their names again the
Sedgewick's I just wanted he said Andrew
Sedgwick Cedric just olt is what the
urgency of that accent is just [ __ ]
tremendous I would list not fair is that
there's so much gravitas yeah that comes
with that accent it just we can't sound
so [ __ ] important everything I say
yeah sorry no that's fine dude so the
oldest brother is like 25 or 26 and he's
a sound engineer so he's got a studio in
their attic he builds a studio in their
attic and he's working on doing sound
mixing for some albums like some pretty
big stuff like them what was his name
his name was Andrew Sedgwick no but so I
would go over there and annoy the [ __ ]
out of his guys is a little kid who I
was so curious about it all his
equipment and stuff his studio and
everything that he got fed up with me
asking him a zillion questions and he
just put a guitar in my hand here play
with this so I started playing with it
and you know six months later I bought
it I saved up my my paper route and I
bought his uh oh you had a paper route
oh yeah yeah oh you say route I said
look at that route route I divert wait
which one did I say you said Ralph
I thought route was Midwest I don't know
see I have a little Midwest I lived in
Michigan when I was when I was little
well I didn't I know I have this weird
mix of accents lived in the South too so
I got a don't be a brat or something no
my dad run from he's a killer so how
many times were you uh the new kid in
school uh four I did it three times it's
brutal
[ __ ] brutal right I still remember
the kids that were nice to me yeah I
still remember when I moved the last
time we moved oh maybe the second time
this kid Keith Hannon the first recess
goes hey man you want to play catch and
he had a tennis ball you like and I was
just like oh thanks that's because he
wasn't bad enough it was bad
enough coming in like we were like four
did we move to the town we were like
four days we were it was already four
days ago it we're right yeah then we
came and I had the very similar thing
man and how they bring you in he's like
you don't just [ __ ] like I didn't just
show up I didn't get on the bus or
anything like that like we went down to
the principal's office cuz we were late
and everything and they were like
alright and they just walked us down and
she just came walking and going okay
class we have a new student they're all
looking at like I kind of like energy my
way through the last one I hung my coat
up like I re I've made a lot of noise I
went over and I sat down and then that's
when I just sat down I felt like course
my desk I felt was like right in the
middle of a class I just felt everybody
glancing me I was like just sit with my
[ __ ] orange hair like I know I know I
don't like it either [ __ ] off so that's
brutal being the new kid is [ __ ] hard
I was all like I was a big kid kinda
that that eight yeah high school I
wasn't that big mm-hmm everyone sort of
caught up with me and then I drew again
later but when I was in fourth grade I
was one of the bigger kids so it seems
like it'd be great but know that all the
kids who were the bigger guys want I had
to like fight them yeah I had to fight
my way through first day of school they
were people were choosing who I had to
fight on the [ __ ] playground like
this is not I thought this kid I
remember I thought this kid this is sort
of kind of when I look about like it was
sort of racist the way the teacher
handle it he was the only black kid and
for some reason we fought we fought like
five recesses in the row and he kept
kicking my ass and finally I remember I
was starting to win and he had these
[ __ ] work boots on and then you just
went like bam bam bam like three times
in my [ __ ] I was like crying right
I was just sitting it crying I remember
she [ __ ] as we used to say back then
bawled him out is what we said to get
yelled at she bawled yelled at him and
then came out I was sitting there crying
she came home and she like rub my head
she even thought so you just got away
with it but I was kind of like maybe
because he lost so cuz I was so pathetic
or maybe I just looked like a little bit
a little beat up Ron Howard I don't know
what Ralph Malph or something there
there ginger yeah she was there
I actually thought about later like why
was she comforting me we both got into
it every [ __ ] recess I was clearly
not like trying innocent to get away
from the kid I don't even know why we
will fight neither because then we ended
up being like friends it was just like
that little kid [ __ ] yeah and I still
remember somehow I slipped and fell and
when I did during the fight yeah yeah I
think he fell down - maybe we just like
with the heel of his boot tongue
sticking out you know little kids when
they're really trying to make an effort
crime I even if I won the fights when I
was a kid because just the emotions just
like I remember say I was at his
birthday party we were playing street
hockey and this one kid who played
hockey was like really good he kept
lifting my stick and kept taking the
puck and he was like [ __ ] twice my
height oh my god knocking your stick up
yeah that guy's so mad I turn around I
just started fighting him and he just he
just kind of like he like leaned back
and kind of like let me [ __ ] get like
3/4 in like missing kinda and then he
just went
blam and passed it blasted me in the
side of the head and I fell down I
started crying I walked away and I just
remember screaming the top of my lungs
and I was walkin I used to cut through
the woods right and people were yelling
from the Guardi to get to school like
you know I'd cut through the woods to
get to my friend's house where you
played street hockey I was already into
the woods and people were screaming okay
come on I'll come back and I was in the
middle of his very self gone [ __ ] his
mother yells one time this is maturity
of the other kid this is no just say I
walk it through the trail
yeah it was always such a real moment
yes I know like I live the same thing
like and what was funny was I came home
and I told my mother what happened and
it never dawned on her to call over
there to drive me all that all that
overly just getting involved with [ __ ]
parenting that people yeah have done
over the last like whatever since we
were kids
all right see when you get home yeah you
know I have things to do or whatever and
then that was kind of it and I remember
the next day the maturity of the other
kid was when we were on the bus I was
like ignoring him and stuff he just kind
of yelled everybody stands up he wait to
get off the bus he yelled hey but let me
talk to you when we get off the bus I
was like alright let me go after a while
that's cool yeah dude this is fifth
grade he really just goes like yes sorry
about that guy man
that's impressive yeah I should have
learned that lesson but I didn't [ __ ]
that kid huh his name you know his name
yeah I don't want to say everybody's not
probably I said because people get all
weird and [ __ ] still rubber actually
real people are still alive yeah his
first name was Tom put it that way at
all [ __ ] dude dude I was way out of
my [ __ ] way class like he didn't even
even the ass-kicking was a gentlemanly
ass-kicking he just gave me one shut the
[ __ ] up to sit down quiet little kid
yeah there was no reason for me to fight
yeah I was just mad cuz he was better
than me it was really immature even for
that age I'm still ashamed of myself so
so anyway so this guy did have given you
a guitar dysphoria that's really [ __ ]
cool yeah it was so cool I guess yeah I
got it well he I mean I could go over
there and play it whenever but but at
some point I was not coming to save up
and buy it I think I bought it for like
75 bucks
did he he'd teach any chords or anything
or was he no no he just left me to it
you know but then I like my girl my
sister's boyfriend was a guitar player
and he was quite a bit older and like so
he showed me some stuff and pretty soon
I was like you know I knew I could
figure out some songs I always had a
decent ear I could pick stuff out and
find it but that was yelling that was
unless you had the money to take lessons
that was the only way to learn back then
that was some snow you know like kids
today the [ __ ] that they could see on
youtube someone would just totally break
that thing down yeah which is gray lever
ething yeah which is great that's why
there's so many monster players out
there but like I would suggest if you
know as they start to show it to sort of
turn you back to the screen and see if
you could just listen to what he's doing
and just just so you're always
developing your ear because you I would
want to be that guy like you know
couldn't figure it out like yeah well
that's like I was like I littering it
out yeah you know but I also think that
maybe one sort of downfall of of
everything being out there for anybody
to learn is you don't develop your own
style of guitar like or whatever it is
right like I play guitar differently
than most people I think because I no
one ever really taught me how to play I
just started playing it right so I have
little little things that I do that are
probably unique to me at least I hope
they are right it's on a technique that
would be like actually that says yeah
that's wrong you're holding your hand
wrong or you know you know it still
sounds good but they're like well but
it's this is what I do so you know but I
think music is like that you know it's
it's your expression whatever whatever
you do that's what you do so yeah it's
it's definitely a it's kind of a great
thing for it and it's also a weird thing
because then I I definitely there's
always like then there's like the top
like [ __ ] it's just I think I feel
like everybody's influence now is is
whatever subject it is the first page
the first three links right becomes like
90% of people's like consciousness
because if you look at I should probably
because I even do that I should probably
I want to go on YouTube next time I go
to look something up to try to just
click to like boy what the [ __ ] is on
page three yeah like I want to get a
page from 99 yeah these you want the
hell's on there the underground yeah
there's a hundred thousand pages to look
at of most things right hundred thousand
hits on how to play you know yeah I
played I played right before I came over
here I'm doing another one of those uh
really the goddamn Comedy Jam so I have
another song I gotta try to get together
with what song well you can't say yet I
don't know ruin it cuz that's because
it's part of the show and they get there
but it's you know I always stay pretty
much you know 70s and 80s right I dress
up like the drummer that I'm gonna tell
it's just completely ridiculous yeah cuz
it's a wanna do I want to do one of
those with those guys I gotta I gotta
connect with them but yeah cuz they were
like you should do one when you come out
in X but now it's been a year yeah you'd
kill it
that'd be so fun dude I wonder if I
don't know if Josh and those guys came
up for the the Toyota and now New York
Comedy Festival well I think they were
there I think they were in New York for
that dude I have so much fun with those
guys every one year I did Montreal the
[ __ ] Comedy Festival just to come and I
played with those guys three nights in a
row oh it's just to do it and then I
then I did a stand-up show but like the
reason I was there
what's the to the music yeah because I
played do I play for [ __ ] like 20
years by myself yeah like it was so -
same thing man but it was such like a
like a kind of thing like why I ended up
becoming a comedian because I was so
introverted and like it didn't dawn on
me until like the mid-2000s I started
playing in the 80s that was just like
right hey kind of the reason for playing
is to interact with other human yet to
share it with people yeah yeah and then
thank God that that show came around and
the first time I got to like well I sat
in with a few other people but the first
time I actually kind of came out people
knew who [ __ ] I wasn't at sat down it
was it was a really like was of such a
fun thing so Music Live is different
than stand-up obviously but it's so
great but I think I just loved it man
it's fun for us too because we're not in
a band and we don't have to deal with
that because I know that guys have met
they're actually in bands it's like the
big thing is how to keep it fun and Beek
when it starts becoming a job like
you've toured with other comedians you
know when you're with comedians you're
gonna have the substance abuse guy you
got the [ __ ] hound the late guy the
egomaniac those are all the same guy oh
yeah that's all Tony woods we all have a
couple of those I'm wondering I'm more
two of those guys from time to time
well yeah I mean what - were you would
you say I'm late and what were the other
ones
substance abuse egomaniac [ __ ] hound I
would say I am I'm definitely late and
maybe a touch of substance abuse I'm
dumb substance abuse guy cigars drinking
I can you I don't know if this makes me
[ __ ] up or anything but like I know I
could shut it off anytime I want to I
just don't want to what do you mean the
drinking or the yeah yeah it's okay I
could go I did it I did it you know I
know you went a few years I went I did
like a year and some change you know
you're in a couple of days I was just
like I just I missed it yeah but it
that's nothing it like completely like
ruins my ruins my
like I mean I I know when to do it much
much more controlled than I used to like
when I stopped I stopped because I was
like holy [ __ ] this is I'm out of
control here alright I got it I got it
way off and and regain my footing so oh
yeah that's like five years I think I
think that's the difference between link
maybe addicts and like [ __ ] up people
like you and I where it's just like I
can just I just want to gets out of
controls like I I'm not gonna do that
for like a month you know stop for a
while yeah although this year you know I
kept saying that and was never a month
it was always like three four days
stressful year this year just a lot of
stuff you know just now it's just what
career stop being busy being busy busy
and all my free time kind of [ __ ]
yeah dissolved and uh sitting there you
know writing on a show it's just you
come home your brain is fried and I
probably should have picked a better
habit but it started to be coming coming
home and having a whiskey right and then
it became - and then it became three
that my wife is finally like hey you
[ __ ] booze bag what are you doing it
literally called me a booze bag and then
I then I I I dialed it back and for me
it's just it's it's could you like
laughs when she'd said that oh god yeah
yeah you weren't like that's good no my
wife is just hilarious what you know
you've got all mad wait a minute I know
yes I did that no that's a bet if that's
your reaction and me and even think
about it yes standing there like yeah
you're right I need to write it in sorry
then you're then it's cool yeah I just
had a couple of bottles hidden behind
toilets and [ __ ] that's totally that's
totally normal no I think that I think
everybody that guy needs to have some
little [ __ ] that's just there's like
there's like a little thing that you
keep just for you know you have to do
right you know what I mean like
everybody's got us maybe some secret
little [ __ ] that's or just dares
whatever it is I saw this guy one time
this old dude I'm gonna move the mic
here I'm sorry I got a lean back at some
point have bad posture I saw this one
time I was staying at this hotel right
right and there was this old dude
standing there all right and like every
night like clockwork because I would
finish the shows I'd come home he come
walking out as long as hotels you could
hear a little dog or whatever now
everything's like a [ __ ] therapy dog
so you can get away with it it's a
working dog working dad you're not
supposed to ask yeah I asked the guy in
the airport he's like you're not
supposed to ask about it well I did I'm
like yeah well if he didn't have a
sweater that said working dog on it I
wouldn't have [ __ ] asked ya what's
its job what's did it major in business
um every night this guy would come out
and he would he'd take out a little
pouch it was tobacco by the way he'd
take that out and he would roll his own
cigarette and it was I just saw it was
like this is this guy's whole ritual you
know sat there and he would only smoke
one right and he would just he would
milk it and he would make it last for
like a half-hour and he would just sit
out there quietly no phone no iPad no
nothing and I remember seeing that going
like yeah I get what that guy is doing
yeah and I wish I had the time to do to
do a little more that we just have that
that I think guys kind of need like
alone time I don't know how women are
women are a little more social but I
agree
they probably needed to I have no idea I
shouldn't speak to them I don't know I
my girl seems content to just be
together and then you know and talk and
chat about everything all the time and
sometimes I'm like why am I getting all
cranky and [ __ ] up right now I'm like
I just need to be by myself like I
needed I definitely need a long time I
think that's why we've got a million
things going on you know we also are
these careers are all-consuming if you
let them be right because we don't have
an office we don't punch a clock we
don't show up at one time and then leave
at another it's just always going on
right you have ideas you have creative
ideas you have scheduled shift in
keeping things going on when I shot my
special right on the 21st of October I
was like oh this year just shot anyone
yep and I'm I stick all I gotta do is
just [ __ ] you know edit that thing
look at it a couple times cuz I know
what I want right and I'm again I'm just
[ __ ] done man I'm have time to
Christmas shop I'm gonna [ __ ] put my
feet up play some drums and blah blah
blah blah I mean I don't know I don't
know what's happening I'm [ __ ] more
uh more busy than ever and it's just
like all of these uh I don't know I just
I don't know editing what's good is good
take a while bro yeah
but I've been able to do it this time
where I sat through and I watched the
whole [ __ ] thing which is something I
you know it's brutal it's you for
[ __ ]
hour and a half and the longer you watch
it you like it's not even funny anymore
yeah you can't get yet it's like oh my
god it's an old bit or yes yeah [ __ ] but
every time I go to do one there's like a
major like I say you know you donate a
kidney he just adds always a chunk I'm
like get that the [ __ ] out of there and
just go right to the end and then we're
done and today I figured out what it was
and it went from you know well I felt a
little bit too long to now being like
[ __ ] it's over already which is that's
perfect that's a sweet spot yeah you
know you know is it it's it's about
seventy seven okay so that's about our
50 and I was sixteen but I mean it was
getting away it was getting like when
they took all the footage from both
shows it was like an hour 38 I'm like
alright there's no way so we cut it down
and then I was like 129 and I'm like I
like everything but I'm just saying it I
think you have to if you like release
like a concert movie I think it's got to
be I I would think like 90 minutes if
people just you yeah and it's meant to
be a feature I just feel like Netflix if
you're gonna go on there and people are
gonna sit down I feel lucky enough I
feel lucky enough that are actually
gonna click on your [ __ ] it's just that
you just gotta like you got to go ACDC
on them you know where they don't play
any ballads you just gotta [ __ ] just
right through yeah yeah unless you like
Chapelle which Chapelle has that way
where he can just really [ __ ] like
bring it that like he's just watching
him do that opening monologue on SNL I
mean just like yeah the level of [ __ ]
that he's doing effortlessly not even
consciously the ups and downs peaks and
valleys and then the huge laughs and
then the poignant moments and all of
that it's just like that that was you
know I'd be happy if I could have done
in an hour and a half what the [ __ ] he
didn't like eight minutes that clinic
that he that he put on so yeah he's
amazing super talented guy man always
was yeah
always was when he was standing where
someone's drinking as white zinfandel
right now the Boston Comedy is Club is
hey so what did you were you shocked
about the election results
I wasn't that shocked
I was we finally met somebody who called
it I knew somebody had to bet Trump I
didn't bet Trump I didn't want a bet
Trump but I did a tour I was on tour in
a lot of southern states mm-hmm for you
know the month leading up to the
election and nothing but Trump signs all
right I mean that's all it's not how
much she couldn't see a single Hillary
son I saw hundreds of Trump signs and I
was like this this could this might be
real do never in a million years that I
think I thought the Hillary was the made
person at the idea to her it was funny I
did I did a conan the day after the
election and like you know i got so many
people like [ __ ] yelling at me
thinking about how the [ __ ] could you
say this about hillary how the [ __ ] have
you said about trump like you can't say
anything about anybody i try to evenly
trash both of them and just say hey and
it'd be nice if people stopped yelling
at each other somehow people missed all
of that yeah and they they you know i
think especially a hillary people
because they're so disappointed that
they just needed somebody I got it's so
much [ __ ] [ __ ] from people and
actually it affects me going like hey
man I saw you on that I go the guy was
like it seemed like you know secretly
you voted for Trump
then he wrote secretly no it's just like
yeah like no I didn't vote for that guy
to I didn't vote for either one of them
I couldn't stand them I like Barney
Barney was my [ __ ] guy I felt like
right after the election for the first
time I felt like Bernie would have won I
was like people really want to change
you know they don't they don't
same old with Hillary yeah and if the if
I was like holy [ __ ] if Bernie had
gotten the nomination he would probably
be the president right now people think
Joe Biden could have won I think just
like like I don't like familiarity
breeds contempt maybe everybody's
[ __ ] filthy there was just something
about like I felt myself saying it like
when I saw Jeb Bush and I saw Kleenex I
just can't deal with another bush or a
Clinton yeah that's a stupid thing to
say but I was just oh it's true there's
some truth to it
because they're my somebody else to lie
to me now
yeah I didn't want this guy you know I'm
not saying Bernie what a [ __ ] solid
everything I will say all this [ __ ] that
Trump's doing is [ __ ] hilarious what
he's like I'm gonna do this won't do
that I'm gonna drain the swamp it's like
dude okay let's just say you actually go
in there and you somehow do this house
Lodi see works like you're gonna [ __ ]
drain the swamp and then what expose all
these people and then they're all gonna
go to jail and like that and they're
gonna be okay with this yeah no I'm
gonna get all the illegal immigrants out
of this country
you're gonna do how are you gonna do
that how are you gonna do that yeah yeah
I'm gonna build a [ __ ] wall from here
to [ __ ] California to Texas
are you really you're gonna you gonna do
all of this there I think there already
is a wall for one isn't there there's
already a fence and a wall through a lot
of it it's like definitely at road here
stop people from coming in by blocking
off three percent of the of the border
it's a tiny it's like they're coming in
any way they could come in well I
thought he was gonna that's the whole
basis of the country he wasn't people
get to come in from all over the [ __ ]
points well there is I actually think
about that [ __ ] it's like there does
become the tipping point well you got
too many [ __ ] people yeah there is
that I mean back in the day yeah we need
him you know we needed all we could get
because of what we were doing which was
underhanded we missed what Amory was
great but we needed to take all gasp
yeah yeah get out there in the front
lines uh come out west hey that's your
land over there go over there and then
provoke them into an attack like what
the whole [ __ ] thing was Shady
yeah from the beginning yeah it's
nothing goes for elections well you know
it's crazy government there they've been
corrupt and been [ __ ] up since the
beginning like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna say the show but I recently did a
show right and one of the comics went up
and this person went and just trashed
Donald Trump this is after after the
show after the election or the show
after the show they went up after the
show after the election right it was
like the you know four five days after
whatever they went right and went in
hard on Trump blah blah blah he's a sex
offender and then on all this type of
stuff and graduate the crowd started
booing right half the ground half the
crowd [ __ ] booze so then the next
person goes up it was a trump supporter
this person goes up and supports Trump
and trashes Hillary then the other half
of the crowd started booing them I've
never seen like so divided dude it's
literally like it's like a great SCC
football game where they play in like a
neutral site like when Florida plays
Georgia and like it's half [ __ ]
Bulldogs half Gators it's [ __ ] insane
like I've never just like that if the
country is so completely divided that
it's a little scary but the thing that I
don't like is that now the people you
know whatever side you're on
where you're seeing the other side as
your enemy right when we're not supposed
to be enemies we're all supposed to we
only here together
dude that ship sailed it I know that's
why I'm saying that's what's shitty what
news came in and balanced out CNN by
being just as ridiculously far to the
other side I mean those show those those
networks that are hilarious like when an
election like what I would do is I would
just whoever was winning I would watch
the other Network just to watch some
stars to see what they said yeah and
just go no I just just for the comedy of
it because I knew there was nothing
nothing I mean I voted who I wanted to
vote for I knew this [ __ ] state was
gonna go with Hillary Clinton I mean
that's a that's a given the oceans vote
for blue and everybody else in the
middle votes for red and then it comes
down to like [ __ ] Ohio Pennsylvania
and Wisconsin evidently North Carolina
which I didn't know about that but what
I was happy was actually was up to date
on all the propositions and voted read
em all me and my wife will read them for
like days in front and like we just
laughing her ass off you like you sit
there like reading there'd be like you
know do you not want them to drill for
oil in the middle of your forehead and
then here's the argument for and I'm
like well that would probably lead to
your death there is no oil in there blah
blah blah blah and then it'd be like the
argument gets actually it's the complete
opposite drilling for oil would actually
save this it's it next thing either you
know maybe I should vote like I didn't
get anything out of those arguments and
then we were just laughing we did you
just eventually look at well who
supported this it'd be like if it was
anything environmentally it's like Ed
Begley Jr alright that guy's been riding
a bike for 30 years okay if he's down
with this I'm going with that bag he's
powered his whole neighborhood if I ride
Nova yeah on a hamster wheel you know
it's funny do we know who huh what
happened with the condoms in porno did
that pass or no nice actually
a thing yes keep porno keep some jobs
here and in in the valley fight so no
they don't have to work on them so now I
think that that was like oh they do they
do okay
oh this is classic Americans we don't
even know well look it up I thought it
used to be that way and now that they've
taken it you could not be further off
the mic so you got to make a quick point
here okay so porno permits we're saying
that maybe it passed but they can't get
permits not Jesus Christ they only had
two things to vote on other than
officers we had to vote on whether or
not we wanted to allow casinos in
northern Jersey and what'd you say I
said no which and it didn't it was no is
overwhelming no they're not gonna be
able to put casinos in northern Jersey
which is in my opinion very good right I
don't hate casinos chris christie's but
i don't think they should be everywhere
I just think Chris Christie is fat and I
thought he's fat enough he doesn't mean
to get that that skinbag
going to church and Mike's even more the
other one was like should we designate
the money from tolls and fuel tax into
Trant public transportation which is
first question it's a B for to begin
with first question is where is it going
now well anywhere else I don't know
where I don't I really don't know where
but it was mentally be allocated toward
that a certain percentage of it
initially and then that got changed
somewhere along the line so ours was
like voted to change it back was
legalizing weed keeping it legal or
something like that it was the condoms
it was like should we repaired there was
one about building up schools and
everything where initially you're like
yeah this is a good thing and then but
the whole thing the whole proposition
was written by these group of people
that are builders and wait a minute I
don't like that the contractors are
writing this [ __ ] up so what's going on
with this there's a lot of interesting
[ __ ] oh yeah that wasn't allowed yeah no
I can't remember and it was like it was
like at least another
there was so many I need a vote on every
one of them yeah but what was great was
we figured out the best we could what it
was and God knows what is attached to
all of that [ __ ] to it you know what I
mean
so I had all my answers before I went in
there so what was taken everybody like
you know a good 20 minutes if you're
reading it for the first [ __ ] time I
Adam also I would just look at the page
yes was up no was down I would just look
at my answer sheet and be like up down
down up and I just threw it I was great
cheating on that test
well for we get out of week we should we
got to get the answer here what's going
on it did not pass it did not pass did
not pass a can't get their permits to
make porn yeah even that is who's who's
who's a conservative behind that that
wants to get porno out of the valley did
the tipper gore moved to the valley
recently remember her thei NPRC
so one way one guy wrote at it that does
not sound real so like I could do that
he's the one guy who supplies the porno
but hey it has to get it's got to get
through some sort of [ __ ] legislative
horseshit right today and get put on the
ballot so he's got money yeah
alright cuz I would say then the guy who
said the rents too damn high what he got
something done remember that guy yeah
yeah it's too damn my rent is too damn
high I hate it when like he kept getting
laughs and kept hanging around and then
like when those politicians like I agree
with them the rent is too darn high I
don't know how those politicians exist
in that level of only cartoons yeah yeah
Al Gore was one of the most was the one
of the worst I saw that was the thing I
think about Trump that was amazing was
watching him just be a be himself which
a lot of people don't like who he was
but he was being a person a lot of
people don't think a good person but
like he's candid you can't you can't
accuse him of not being me dude it was
like they was sitting at the table but
it was politicians and he was the guy
running the table and no one could get
him I couldn't [ __ ] him none they could
not figure out they're like this guy
doesn't care about anything how do we
pin him down
and he didn't give a [ __ ] about what he
says from one minute to the next
he didn't care about like oh oh she's
allowed to talk and I can I'll grate
three against one when he said that it
was it was [ __ ] because it's a great
ticket but it was brilliant like do what
he did I mean I'm not happy that it's
certainly these [ __ ] guys that he's
putting together I joked to my last
podcast you know he was telling me he's
gonna have change and everything that
was just going he's just doing the exact
time it's like fuller house yes bring it
back this old show it was like the
expendable version of the Expendables of
Republicans it's his duty it's the whole
thing to him was just a game it seems if
you talk if you see him interviewed now
it's just like he's basically like oh I
won and that was it it doesn't matter
how you know it's just one you know
swayed about the summer and they're like
but you're gonna you're doing all this
stuff you said you weren't gonna do it
he's like well who else is gonna do it
basically it's like Marx Brothers [ __ ]
like you can't just say who else but the
thing about the media's they had no
follow-up cuz they never dealt with the
guy like this who would just admit to
yeah you know yeah typical follow-up
doesn't work because they call him out
on it and he just says yeah whatever who
cares and it says something else well
the the back in the day when somebody
would call when they would call a
politician out they try to get out of it
and they would stammer and then they
would just keep you know hitting them
with it until just the whole
embarrassment of the situation the
person would drop out he just would
admit to it and they had nothing yeah
and they're like well when they said all
you supposed to be bad I keep using this
as an example that would like you you
know you've said this about women you've
said that about women you said this
about I guess not and I cuz I said that
about Rosie O'Donnell and it got a huge
laugh and then the female reporter goes
like now you've said that about other
women to India's because he's probably
right it's over
and it was already a joke and she
couldn't even like or anybody in that
panel couldn't have been like you're
probably right so you're saying you are
sexist is that what you're saying do you
think that like and that I still think
because of what the [ __ ] he represented
he could have just been like yes I am
sexist yeah I can't believe you're not
sitting here making me a pie
or something they get out of here and
let the men handle it clearly people
were not put off by that I don't know
but it's hard to tell what's what's true
and what isn't anything you read about
Hillary in the last three months or five
months or whatever could have been taken
out of context absolutely put in a way
to make her look you know show her in a
certain light and same with Trump yeah
it'd be silly to assume that one side is
doing it one side the other is not no
they are like you don't amazing it's
very difficult to tell what the [ __ ] is
real and what isn't you know you know
it's funneled out there news from
[ __ ] Twitter Facebook all of that I
um you know cameo buzz daily on Twitter
by the way real Ben Bailey the real Ben
Bailey Bai le why.com
the real Ben Bailey calm I um I was
actually amazed the election night when
they had the pictures of each candidate
and was finally one that the other side
hadn't picked I was just like Oh Hillary
she looks like a nice person
Donald it looks like a cool guy yeah
they look he's always like you know the
scowl and he had like the things like
that rudy giuliani picture that the left
is using where he looks like he's
roaring he just came up from the flames
of hell that thing is [ __ ] you could
you can do that to anybody especially
and when you're that old it you know
it's such an effort just to speak your
face is gonna contort when they just
have to do take a couple of pictures
you're gonna look like Satan and then
Hillary always just had that crazy
[ __ ] smile and the bobblehead thing
going and done really unflattering a
light like she looked like you know I'll
- they did have a skillet or they did
everything they possibly could to both
of them Mike Trump like his eyebrows by
the end of the election were like
beneath his eyes well Frank it's joke
the fact that he actually has one points
out a point that he made repeatedly
through the campaign which is that the
whole system's is [ __ ] it doesn't work
yeah but I will tell you all those
people that think that he's somehow
gonna get them out of that [ __ ] hole
is that's it's ridiculous now you know
it's they don't give it's on you it's on
you when they they try to act like these
these people are gonna save you [ __ ]
ass they're not no they can't know and
that's the uplifting message of this
podcast
could be worse dude there's a there's
like a billion people literally a
billion people in China that live in
abject poverty I've told and are
brainwashed into thinking that that's
you know that's their place I don't know
it's billion people how would you even
begin to have you seen this is the thing
tackle up an issue like that
have you seen no way to do it it's it's
just that's a that's how it is
have you seen those cities like are
there they have a few cities over there
that have so many [ __ ] people like it
literally looks like there's a fire but
it's just the polluted air it's just the
area it's just the air so like when they
were having the Olympics over there at
some point when they were gonna shoot
something you know film it for the world
to see they told everybody to like not
drive or use any machinery or anything
god knows what would happen to you if
you did like I don't know 24 hours or
three days or some [ __ ] before they just
let all of that [ __ ] in the air just
settle down onto the ground because
that's that's what it is
yeah cuz it's all like even like out
here like a lot of times people think
the haze is smog but like haze like smog
is brown but haze is that clear thing
and that haze is all the dust and all
the [ __ ] that we're picking out to drive
around yeah so everybody I think
basically what's that new thing the kids
are doing you act like a mannequin or
some [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah they made
like the a billion people or half a
billion people [ __ ] do that people go
swimming you guys just have to hold
still yeah till we're done with the
100-meter back there's a couple more
things on there though you have any
lecture any more movies are something
like do you know like the next one that
you're gonna do as far as the short film
I don't I think I might do another
episode of blam I like I'd like it a lot
and it was really fun and like the idea
was that another comic or you know actor
friend of mine will be they'd be the
villain probably another comedian and so
we just keep doing those but I can
definitely see that being a series it
web series a webisode it was initially
was gonna be a web series but then I
made the first one and I was like I
don't know if I want to put all that
into this every single time just on my
own right I might rather try
some other stuff and see what people
like you know get some feedback once the
stuff is out there hey Kel that leads to
some the next thing you know you have
you have something on you got something
on [ __ ] Amazon or Netflix yeah like
you're walking down a red carpet people
yelling Ben what are you wearing what
are you wearing
I don't know and then they go back then
they go back through all yours and a
recently unearthed gem meet at Ray's and
you said we also have yeah for 12 years
now it's a period film well I actually
was anyway I want to see it because I
want to see like I cuz I'm I'm one of
those guys that I love seeing New York
and you love into any era that it isn't
now like I love seeing it in the 90s now
I love seeing it in the 80s I love 70s
of this [ __ ] and then 60s and 50s when
it goes back is yeah like i watch i
watch old [ __ ] movies for that reason
like sometimes I watch an old movie I'll
see a guy driving down Sunset and you
just see how spread out the buildings
are yeah yeah and I mean at the shooting
so you don't know about the traffic but
it's just like some of that stuff where
it's just you could just so see the
hills and stuff is like yeah that back
then that's where they had like you want
to go shoot a mountain lion and you like
walked out your backyard it's right he's
just right down the road yeah in in LA
so anyways I should say I or before we
go sorry I also have to podcast shows
that are gonna be on this on a new
website oh cool
one of them's a storytelling show
beautify remember DC Benny and I used to
do that show urban myth yeah wait what
venue did that was that I just almost
got to this early when we're talking
about zinc bar cuz that was the original
sink bar was on Houston Street yes and
that's where I would do
urban myth every Tuesday the new podcast
I have it's called tall but true
it's a storytelling show it's bit it's
pretty much ribbon myth oh cool has a
podcast so it's like the two of us tell
a story and then a guest tells a story
so love to have you do that yeah man I
call into that if you want and then
another one and that'll all be on the
real Ben Bailey calm yeah and then one
where my girl and I it's called speaking
of movies we watch a movie and then we
just talk about the movie afterward
those are all good we love which we did
anyway and then one day we're like we
always have these great conversations
after we watch a movie let's just start
recording them so you
commend a movie you've seen lately that
you liked dude I watched you've probably
seen it I'm Way behind but I just
watched Batman vs Superman I liked it
I've loved it man you've already seen it
oh yeah
oh yeah it was great I liked it I said
that yesterday at Benson's podcast Doug
loves movies and everybody's like what
they were like they thought it was
turning what I like the body's awesome I
like the sorry
I like the how the way they had are like
the the government getting involved
going we he just had this guy acting
unilaterally and whatever the [ __ ] that
means you know just just basically
helping out a little [ __ ] once and
people claiming him and all that I was
just gonna I the countable this really
yeah that actually seemed like some [ __ ]
that they would do and then demonize him
and all that like I always forget movies
the second I saw him but that thing
stuck out with me I really liked that I
thought it was great man and it's it's
you know if you ever seen Watchmen
remember that one that's the same
director Zack Snyder I think his name is
he made the Watchmen which is like super
dark superhero movie right based on this
graphic novel which is awesome you
should check it out you'd love it
there's a gator called the comedian
oh cool superhero called the comedian
he's like super dark the only thing I
don't like about Superman movies is it
always comes down to the Kryptonite it's
always it's never you know bangs the
wrong girl it's you just know okay
when's the Green Chain getting wrapped
around his neck here once it could have
happened yeah the only thing that can do
it the only thing he's too powerful
that's the thing it almost gets a little
boring well well Ben we finally got you
on the podcast I finally got to play jam
with you man it was [ __ ] awesome and
continued success
check out all things Ben Bailey at the
real Ben Bailey calm you can also get
there by going to 3b TV net that's three
baby tv.com B is and baby I should say
doesn't it dotnet sorry unfortunately
it's not man dot now I'm is like some
kids who have a site with funny videos
that suck I shouldn't say that that's me
I know I know what you're okay but it's
not mine you you went for the joke that
three B TV dotnet alright I'm gonna read
a little bit of advertising and that's
gonna be it I hope you guys have a good
weekend I'll I'll see on Monday you
[ __ ] cool
all right here's the advertising here
Nia can you stop moving this [ __ ] around
track her we're all losers Newsweek
reports the average American wastes 55
minutes a day looking for things they
own but can't find get the [ __ ] out of
here 55 minutes I'm a dope I look for 48
[ __ ] newsweek no kidding
share a story of when you've lost
something you needed I remember one time
I was taking a dump but I was like
where's the toilet paper so I'm walking
around with my [ __ ] belt around my
legs tracker makes losing things a thing
of the past and I'll tell you how to get
one for free in a minute tracker is a
coin size device that's locates
misplaced keys wallets bags computers
anything in seconds just pair track or
two you smatphone attach it to anything
and find its precise locations with the
tap of a button it's that easy lose your
phone oh [ __ ] there it is press a button
on tracker and your phone rings even if
it's when it's on silent creepy tracker
is finding over a million misplace items
each day order yours and never lose
anything again listeners get listeners
listeners to this show [ __ ] get a free
tract or a Bravo with any order go to
the tracker comm and enter the promo
code BRR
the hardest thing a level F you'll ever
have to find is their website go to
tracker calm right now and enter the
promo code BIR for your free copy one
free tracker Bravo with any order again
that's tracker com promo code berm hey
where's the next read oh there it is
thank you tractor lift you know about
lift right it's the app that gets you
rides in minutes on-demand 24/7 for less
than the cost of a cab if you tried lyft
you know what I mean but lyft you just
download the app request a driver they
show up in three and a half minutes
average that's really fast in case you
didn't know there every lift driver is
fully vetted through their ten-point
safety standard have you ever killed
anyone
- indeed jerk off when you're driving 3
right they go through the whole thing so
you be safe including criminal and DMV
background checks you'll know you'll get
around quickly and safely why can't I
read tonight lyft drivers are rated
after every ride it's only the best
stick around you don't have to worry
about getting into a filthy card with
some creepy dude with lifts you can tip
in the app with obviously weights to
have your drivers I mean 9 out of 10
lift rides get a perfect 5 star rating
from the passengers it's just better
all-around experience what happens on
that tenth one we'll leave that up
bigger isn't always better
you [ __ ] size Queen lyft isn't the
biggest ride-sharing app but it's the
fastest-growing in the highest rated one
I'm talking quality over quantity you
know where they're taking a shot at here
it rhymes with scoober um thanks to
lifts you got an easy way to avoid drunk
driving you never have to bum a ride and
you never have to worry about parking a
lot of people are actually getting ride
getting rid of their cars and relying on
lyft to get around and you know what I
don't blame them what if I didn't say
that you wrote that well if you live in
Nebraska I think you're out of your
[ __ ] mind right now lyft is offering
our listeners a special deal get three
rides up to ten dollars each that's a
thirty dollar value you get those for
free when you enter the promo code bill
burr just download for free the lyft app
today and enter the promo code bill burr
in the payments section you'll start
with three free rides up to ten dollars
each that's up to a $30 value
that's promo code bill burr once again
enter promo code bill burr not always
stop this [ __ ] thing press home to
unlock
Jesus Christ all right yeah I got two
more here oh here we go
Berto boo boo me undies me undies why
did you vote for Trump but dude dude do
me undies me undies America is taking a
dump what were you supposed to [ __ ]
do they got rid of Bernie and they had
that [ __ ] [ __ ] alright picture a
world we're putting on a new pair of
underwear isn't just fresh you're
stepping into a better day think of what
think about it underwear it's the first
thing you put on the last thing and take
off unless you're Matthew McConaughey
why would you settle for anything less
than the best feeling underwear on the
planet the undies focuses solely on the
on producing the most comfortable
underwear you've ever experienced your
balls will thank you
your [ __ ] will also thank you no it
wasn't bad my friends at me undies sent
me a pair a few uh a few pairs a while
back and now I can't imagine wearing
anything else evidently it really makes
each day that much better for the price
of two cocktails me undies will deliver
your favorite new pair of underwear
right to your [ __ ] doorstep better
better de guarantee you try them on if
they're not the most comfortable
underwear you know do a couple of
scissor kicks yeah you're nuts feel if
they're not the best feeling undies you
ever had they'll refund you and let you
keep your first pair for free included
in the price is the sweet touch of modal
Modell a special fabric made of the
best-in-class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times
softer than cotton now they've been
saying that for a year and the cotton
people have not said [ __ ] so I'm
believing that's true these uber cozy
undies are sold exclusively on the
undies website where you'll enjoy free
shipping in the US and Canada the rest
of you can go [ __ ] yourselves
and for a limited time everyone in my
audience gets 20% off their first order
but you have to go to our special URL me
undies com / / with me undies that with
the me undies better day guarantee you
have nothing to lose so don't wait any
longer go to my undies calm / bar right
now for 20% off your first order that's
beyond ease calm / burn and lastly but
not leastly simply fave
ever find yourself almost all the way to
work or maybe you're out with your
family and friends and you get that
nagging feeling why did I marry this
woman no not that nagging feeling you
start thinking did I close that window
did I lock the door you just don't know
it could drive you nuts
well you don't have to worry about that
anymore when you got simply safe home
security
you don't buy any nice [ __ ] you know she
wouldn't care either but that's a
different story it's a nice extra layer
of protection to know simply safe is
there simply safe has an arsenal of
senses to protect your entire home and
keep your family safe simply safe got
rid of everything that makes home
security such a pain there's no
long-term contracts no hidden fees they
won't gouge you it's $14.99 a month
that's three times less than what other
companies judge and here's some big news
simply safe just released its brand-new
high-definition security camera the
camera is different this camera is
different it connects to your security
system and sends your smartphone a video
the second something happens at home hey
honey look at that guy stealing all our
[ __ ] you can see the stubble on the side
of his face this this HD is incredible
you can see everything that's going on
so you won't have to wonder anymore call
to action okay
check out simply safes new camera today
just go to simply save bird calm right
now that simply saved bird calm hi
simply safe bird calm alright that's it
now I got once again I got to hit the
home button I got to do the whole
password [ __ ] thing
hey what's going on it's bill burr is
the Monday morning podcast and it's late
in the day and I finally got to it and
this is my fourth attempt there trying
to do a good one get a good one number
that line what did what movie set from
Fast Times at Ridgemont High mr. hand
you remember him you know the guy who
played that he was in my favorite
Martian and he took that gig back in the
early 60s and so like 30 [ __ ] years
every time somebody ran up to him they
said hey it's that [ __ ] Martian guy
and he hated life and he hated that
[ __ ] show and then he did that show
movies Fast Times at Ridgemont High and
one day the clouds parted and some young
kid came walking up to him said hey
mister hand and evidently he was really
excited isn't that a nice show business
story I don't know what the [ __ ] that
has to do with my podcast for this
[ __ ] bus that is in front of me that
is not moving go you're a boss there you
go merge you [ __ ]
anyways if you're new to my page or my
website I do one of these every single
week and people send me questions and I
try to answer them to the best of my
ability I try not to say [ __ ] during the
podcast but occasionally it slips out
when there's a brought us driving 2
miles an hour what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me I can't say words lately I was
working at Zanies in Nashville and I
kept stumbling over words and then I
started thinking why I keep stumbling
over these words and then I almost
started stuttering on stage and speaking
of which if you came out to see me at
Zanies in nashville tennessee i just
want to say thank you very much and even
though i just said thank you very much
you might have sensed a little bit of
anger underneath that and it has nothing
to do with you guys it has to do with
the fact that there aren't enough hours
in the day today
and I'm [ __ ] frustrated and I
basically only have about 10-15 minutes
to do this podcast and you know usually
usually I go on for about 45 minutes but
today or whatever half hour this is
going to be like an EP kind of like Guns
and Roses
that live album except I'm not going to
drop the n-word you know so / if you're
listening to this if you're one of the
14 people who listens to my podcast
you're not going to feel awkward or
after have to [ __ ] explain yourself I
don't [ __ ] know people you know what
you know what I got nothing i got
nothing this week I got nothing funny to
say I am [ __ ] burnt out I just did
back-to-back weeks on the road plus a
college you want to hear you want to
hear my my week I was in I was in
Washington DC then I was in LA and then
I went to Colorado then I flew to
Indianapolis did the Bob and Tom show
and I had a night off the night before
and because my brain never shuts off I'm
like well why the [ __ ] would I just
chill out in Indianapolis when I can
drive for [ __ ] hours up to Detroit
and go to a Red Wings game and that's
what I did
except I thought it was only a two-hour
drive and it turned out it was a [ __ ]
four-hour drive four and a half actually
and I went out there was red winks
penguins which turned out to be one of
the games of the year but I had to leave
before the third period ended and I
missed the Penguins come back and went
in overtime but I still got to go to
that arena and I couldn't believe how
small it was you know there was no upper
deck it just kind of went straight up
you know it was kind of an I don't know
an old school building in like a 1975
kind of way but I was really cool and
the fans were awesome and you know I
don't like going on that expansion [ __ ]
and I don't like fair with the fans and
that choice got good fans and there were
a lot of Pittsburgh Penguins fans there
talking a lot of [ __ ] even when they
were down for two after two periods and
I missed them all talking [ __ ] when they
came back and won 7-6 and [ __ ]
overtime and where was I
driving by a [ __ ] cornfield in the
middle of Indiana by then so my brain
right now is frazzled and you know you
might wonder a row what the [ __ ] is
wrong with Bill and you know I don't
have any answers I'm driving a hybrid
just drank three quarters of a Sam Adams
beer one of their seasonal brews and I'm
on my way to a writers meeting because I
have to go write some sketches for
something that I'm shooting and I'm
exhausted this is one of these times
when I just want to sleep for [ __ ]
nine 10 hours and wake up the next day
and just stare at the [ __ ] wall but I
can't because I have to do this I have
to somehow put my voice into a sketch
which is not an easy thing to do I find
it's very hard for me to write sketches
because I write very setup punch set up
punch there's not a lot of layers
there's not a left model left turns you
know it's just like my act there's a lot
of screaming and the f-word so we have
to figure out how to do that and we're
at a red light so I think it's time for
a podcast question look at this this is
just like the Cash Cab okay no question
we're number one have you ever been
asked to write material for another
comedian first of all look at this
[ __ ] guy riding down the street with
a bicycle I think when that people do
that they put a reflector on their back
and then all of a sudden they just they
feel like they're like it's sort of like
a motorcycle on some level they start
riding with traffic like their Kevin
Bacon and Quicksilver you know nothing
makes me want to lean over and open my
passenger door and commit vehicular
manslaughter like some [ __ ] turn your
life somebody never like saw like that
dude you know what I don't what the [ __ ]
was that saw what was the question have
I ever been asked to write material for
another comedian yes yes I have I've
written for I wrote for one roast is
Shaquille O'Neal roast and I got to
admit you know at first I started
writing the jokes and I was like I don't
want to write jokes for another comedian
I want to write them for me and I want
to be able to say them so I get to laugh
but then I realized what's cool about a
roast is you're not at work like writing
for comedians Act where they're then
going to go on HBO and kill with some
joke and get credit for it it's it's a
very specific thing it's not like I have
a chunk
material about Shaquille O'Neal so what
do I care and I wrote it and evidently
it went really well people and the
writers were on my guests liked it and I
got a real kick out of it and I got one
joke on the air and I believe the joke
was something about watching Shaquille
O'Neal play basketball was like watching
a [ __ ] [ __ ] something along those
lines
something along those lines of that he
was just such a big dude yeah I such a
big [ __ ] dude that even when he dunks
the ball it doesn't look good he looks
like a fat kid Duncan a ball in like a
nerf hoop set and that was basically
that was basically it
I went the cheap route I use [ __ ] as a
reference you know so I'm not proud of
it but I got on the air all right here's
another one do you agree that the reason
many TV shows are abruptly canceled the
reason many TV shows are abruptly
canceled is due to the media's attempt
to control what we watch such as reality
TV ok
the media's attempt as if the entire
media is working together if you're in
the conspiracy theory I would work a
little higher up the ladder and try to
see who owns media in this country and
you'd be surprised it's not that many
people so i don't know i don't think
reality TV is an attempt to for them to
control what we watch i just think it's
really cheap and it's uh is something
mesmerizing about watching 10 losers in
a house talk [ __ ] about each other as
much as i make fun of it the desk I just
[ __ ] bump into me what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you you [ __ ] idiot
I just [ __ ] rear-ended me hang on a
second
[ __ ] dude there's no [ __ ] away he
just did that I swear to God I think
some guy just literally tap my bumper
hang on a second you know this would be
great if we get to a [ __ ] red light
cuz I know we didn't hit it hard enough
hold on hold on a second did you bump
into me hang on a sec did you just bump
into me you didn't okay I don't know it
was my car or not I wonder why you had
such a nonchalant look on your face I'm
like this so you didn't alright I'm just
making sure all right sorry about this
okay I uh huh okay so anyways everything
I you didn't bump into me I think my car
just had like a hiccup but it literally
felt like somebody just tapped my phone
and I looked in the rearview mirror this
guy was right on my [ __ ] ass you guys
almost hurt in LA moment what if I
fought him I want to [ __ ] after I
have enough speakerphone dude then they
could have used my podcast in court then
I finally would have got past like 15
[ __ ] listeners god damnit
so is that was a moment right there that
was a moment that almost happened what a
stupid question who did you just poke
into me uh no I didn't oh okay
Jesus can you believe I'm not a private
investigator with that some sort of
[ __ ] police work alright so anyways
anyway I gotta wrap this podcast up cuz
I'm out where the [ __ ] I'm at so this
goddamn writers thing that I'm doing but
you had a Mitch you know that was pretty
exciting that for a second alright let's
let's try to blow through some of these
more some more of these questions before
I get the phone thanks to everybody who
came out to see me at Zanies in
Nashville Tennessee had an awesome time
and literally tons more people showed up
since the last time which really made me
feel good that you know people actually
saw my special they liked it and it made
him want to come out and I'm really
psyched about that and I know I've been
telling you guys I'm putting the dates
up for 2009 they're definitely getting
up this week I talked to my Booker and
there's supposed to be an emailing me
something so I'll get the dates up
on my website up on my myspace page
please come out to see me and you'll
watch me put together my next special
that hopefully I will take this summer
coming summer so anyways there's a long
question about corporate America hey
Bill let me tell you why I effin hate
corporate America especially Verizon
exclamation point they sold me a
blackberry that recently for the fifth
time the keyboard wouldn't work couldn't
make our answer calls and couldn't do
anything each time what would happen I
go to Verizon they would fix it for me
but the last time a few weeks ago a
buddy of mine and the army was called
the day before he shipped off to Iraq
and I was unable to answer the call
Jesus that sounds like a Lifetime movie
I can't answer the phone I need to say
goodbye so I went to Verizon furiously
as you should have demanding an
explanation on why they sold me such a
shitty phone they told me that they
could do was replace it with the same
model phone in which my response was all
you'd be doing is giving me a shinier
piece of [ __ ] god bless you god bless
you that's exactly what you should have
said and they should have taken the
phone and bury it inside of his head and
blamed him for that design as if he
designed it alright leading me and this
basically led him to sign up with AT&T
and now Verizon wants to charge me with
$125 early termination fee I've been
arguing my case with them on the phone
trying to explain to them that I still
had Verizon I wouldn't be able to make
this phone call they kept telling me
that they understand why I'm except
upset in which my response was great so
if you understand why you still ask for
my money and basically there is no way
that I'm going to buckle and give it
into them good good for you I keep
calling them disputing them I'll keep
calling them disputing up for two years
if I have to to me it's a matter of
principle
because what pisses me off is how these
corporations are allowed to conduct
business you know I don't need the rest
read the rest
exactly exactly it's bigger than you and
they have more money than you and they
can wait you out and then they can send
you [ __ ] to a collection agency because
you're the little guy and they know that
you're not going to do that this is what
you want to do you want
you got to do that old-school thing just
go I want to speak to a manager and you
keep going up the ladder asking to speak
to somebody about them get everybody's
name keep using words like ridiculous
and outrageous like this is ridiculous
this is outrageous and just do it the
way like an old lady would and just just
don't get off the phone don't ever curse
if you never curse then they can't dig
they can't hang up on you I'm full of
[ __ ] I don't know what to do you know
what go burn down their [ __ ] building
or something but I'm sorry man I really
didn't answer that question well but uh
I gotta go in and do this meeting so
whatever thanks for listening to the
Monday morning podcast I know this was
real short but hey we had a nice yelling
match with a potential yelling match
with another person in a car
which turned out to be friendly how bad
did you guys want that to escalate into
violence you know you did and you could
have heard me get my ass kicked
now that guy just roll down the window
like I've ever taken a karate class it
was [ __ ] ridiculous but fortunately
[ __ ] didn't go down that way so anyways
it was very short very exciting TJ
Hooker episode of the Monday morning
podcast keep listening please keep
sending the questions and that is it god
bless all yeah please come and see me at
Caroline's in New York City the first
week in December and that is it and I
apologize to the guy who I thought hit
my car but really didn't if he's a
podcast listener all right dude that's
it all right guys take it easy bye
guys take it easy bye all right take it
easy bye guys take it easy